congressman jim jordan is a conservative
he was there today he's the
highest-ranking republican on the
committee he joins us tonight
congressman thanks so much
for coming up so you tweeted today a
tweet that was heartening i think to a
lot of people you said
big texts out to get conservatives
clearly true
it's time they face the consequences
right so to the
many frustrated viewers out there who
don't think republicans
have forced them to face any
consequences for the past four years
tell us specifically if you would what
those consequences are going to be
well you got to change you got to work
on section 230 we're looking at that
right now you may have to
the justice department is looking at
current anti-trust law to go after these
companies right now and frankly we may
have to change the law
and we also have to continue to do what
you've been doing and thank you for
doing
that calling them out every time we see
the bias
every time we see them become the
facilitators of the mob
to cancel people we have to continue to
call that remember tucker
twitter went after me two years ago i've
been talking about this for a couple
years
they shadow been four members of
congress 435 in the house 100 in the
senate
only four gates meadows nunes jordan get
get shadow banned by twitter and of
course they just told us
it was just a glitch are you i asked i
said
what'd you put in the algorithm the
names gates meadows nunes jordan i think
i said that on your show
no you did and of course we agreed but
i'm a talk show host and we've got you
know four
million viewers or whatever but my job
is to talk
lawmakers are tasked with running the
country and passing our laws
by definition and these companies
operate with a special carve out
provided them by congress
and congress has never done anything
to rein them in and so we've got what 96
days till the election
are there gonna be any consequences
until then well no you just mentioned
the most important thing
in 96 days 97 days whatever that number
is
it's important we re-elect donald trump
and take back the house because do you
think joe biden kamala harris and jerry
nadler
are going to fix this do you think
they're actually going to stop big tech
from attacking conservatives and
censoring conservatives no
i don't think so so that's why the most
important republicans aren't in control
we're working working on the senate
working with the senate on this 230
issue
we're looking at every remedy we can
because there has to be a remedy for
what they're doing to conservatives
okay the most important thing is to take
back the house and make sure donald
trump is re-elected okay trump's in the
right position
it seems very difficult for any
candidate or party
to win anything if all the information
about the race is controlled by people
who are working for the other side which
is where we are now so without whining
about why nothing has been done so far
let me ask you no
sense in brenner's taking money from
google google is your second
biggest campaign contributor in the last
cycle why do you think they would give
you money
and why would you talk look if they want
to exercise their first amendment
liberties and give me money that i
raised three million dollars
last quarter if google gives me a few
thousand dollar check god bless them
that doesn't change who i am you saw
that today in the committee
i went after i went after him for the
very issue you just raised tucker in
google tried to tailor their features to
help clinton in
key states that's directly from the
email the head of their multicultural
marketing
section i get it i mean again i'm a talk
show host we talk about this stuff all
the time but where's the part where we
say we're yanking
your liability exemption one that we
don't have at fox news but they somehow
have
where they can't be sued for garbage on
their site
and so like where's the effort to do
that i i'm frustrated i think a lot of
our viewers appreciate it i'd just like
to know like when's that
working on it right we're working on it
right now with folks in the senate josh
hawley is working on that we're our
staff is working with with
uh center staff on that issue what is
the way what's the best way to structure
that language we're looking at that
we're also what the the justice
department is doing bill barr is looking
at this issue
as well so that's the rim now we may
have to write some other law there are
three possible remedies
here all i know is there is a big
problem and there has to be a remedy
we're looking at which is the best
course of action to take but none of it
happens tucker
none of it happens if jerry nadler's
still in charge of the judiciary
committee
and joe biden and kamala harris get
i'm certainly not advocating for jerry
nadler having more power than he does
obviously he's appalling i just
again i think most people watching feel
justified frustration that here we are
right at the edge of the election
and it's pretty hard to win anything if
these people continue to interfere in
our democracy and i'm sure you're sure
that
no i i do you know the good news is in
2016 in spite of what google did
the american people saw it for what it
was and donald trump was elected i think
it's going to happen again but we got to
keep our eye on him and that's why i
raised that issue
in the hearing today twice with mr
pachai
at google congressman thanks for coming
on time i appreciate it